welcome my name is Orlando y'all with a
third and there's some index cards being
passed out and pens and as more people
come in will continue to give those
cards I do want to just take a moment
and acknowledge and remember Tom
Lawrence and just to have a moment of
silence silence for us so I asked us to
have a moment of silence right now
please thank you
I went to invite Jemima a graduating
senior on campus a freshman counselor
first-year counselor to just come and
greet us
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening everyone and welcome my
name is Jemima Aunt Jemima Ramona has
personified I'm a senior campus but most
importantly welcome to everybody you can
yell give yourself a round of applause
[Music]
okay so your heels campus on a Wednesday
night y'all know you gotta do better
than that so can you give yourself
better on the road so welcome to our
town hall with McRae on the intersection
of mental health faith culture and
social justice ingenuity from everyone
who organized this thank you so much for
being here and now I would like to
invite kinesio Georgetown to come and
serve as I'll open again see you can you
give her a round of applause hey
everybody I'm currently CEO but I'm
really here because I have the pleasure
of introducing you all to one of our
student wonderful student performers and
then I'll get to introduce professor
Addie as well but just to say a little
bit about my friend Anita Norman Anita
is a senior here at Yale College she's
majoring in American Studies with a
focus on let me make sure I get this
right with the focus on Visual and
Performing Arts which is really awesome
and I had the pleasure of having her in
one of a docu-series that I've produced
and she just blew us away by just her
her radiance and the light that she
brings and actually I did some stalking
online and she is the 2014 Poetry Out
Loud world national champion and has
been incredible
and she has she has been asked to come
back multiple times to to inspire youth
and she did a poem that won her or got
her to like the final stages and it was
called I think I'm right about this let
the light end right let the light in
found that on the website but it's
intimate and so I think though I was
like that's interesting that she did
something like left the light in because
I think that's what she does and so she
brings light to every room she's in
so I hope that you all will enjoy her I
know that you all will and I'll be back
saying she do is professor at yesterday
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone i am from Little Rock
Arkansas but also Memphis Tennessee and
I grew up in the southern black church
and maple more as my great-grandmother
I'm gonna talk about her a little bit
and she would just absolutely have a cow
fit and a hernia or something if she
knew that I was reading from a paper so
don't tell her okay but some things have
changed and I've been thinking a lot
about recent events on campus and just
my time here so I wrote something else
and that's why it's on paper and to me
home is essential for centering and
grounding and I think that we have the
potential to create home in ourselves it
doesn't have to be a place a physical
place but in the interactions that we
have with one another oftentimes the ELL
students complain it's not genuine we
asked the same questions we say the same
things and my goal for the year and my
goal in this introduction is just to
remind us you know that we do come from
someplace remember those things that
make you excited that make your eyes
well up or
you know that make you just crack crack
up I will be making a lot of references
about home so it's about culture it's
about mental health and it's about faith
and hopefully that comes across here
it's a bunch of vignettes this is for
the brother that flipped a coin that
always landed on heads there was never a
50/50 chance God always knew for certain
this is my busted lip and black eye cuz
round one never ends ends up running
around the block up the stairs when mama
is yelling didn't I tell you a lot of my
gardenias and I was just starting mine
and singing ritual on my way to the gas
station for a pickle hubba bubba and
double dutch skipping rocks and fishing
rods realizing growing up is an
obligation to my younger self to be all
the beauty i saw and butterflies
breaking their backs every time they
dare to fly this is sara vaughn and
Billie Holiday laughing at the dream
deferred I stole it back and grew it up
in my naps stacked okay when I realized
I was a lamppost I was staring at the
collar bone of magnolia trees who
birthed sunlight from beneath eyelids
that whisper sleepy dreams celestial
braids flowing down my back as my
great-grandmother greased an itchy scalp
oil dug her fingers in the side of my
arm said you got breath flowing like
windows down on highway 365 don't roll
on my baby don't forget what you know we
face our fears at the fulcrum of a lone
and awake and lucid meet our demons on
the curb in passing when I realized I
had seen one she had a cigarette
dangling from her lips reaching in her
bag for another she asked me for a
lighter how easily we infatuate
ourselves and
vacuums of empty on a real I've been
sitting in the open of my windows for
days where leaves fold into romantic
getaways and the intimacy of their brush
it's like the way I wish our words would
fold into the corners of each other
waxing a warm sort of world but it all
fades to black I know how bees make
honey sweet and how seeds become
dandelions field formations for wishes
come true I know that tears fall and the
shape of rain torrential downpours
happen inside the folds of a pillowcase
I know about sitting on blankets on the
back porch with my cousin pilling corn
husks talking about nothing it seems
like those were the best times I know
about broken plates and the hours it
takes to glue them together
I know people break to it I know about
circles the deep ones that make my face
into a shadow of itself they take light
with them and make eyes into just
sockets I know about disappearing
finding a mirror and talking things back
into existence there's a Ledge and I
know about letting my feet dangle till
the roaring ceases to make my stomach
boil I know about light rooms that feel
like dark rooms and loud rooms that feel
like lonely rooms I know in some places
the clouds seem closer to you than they
do the sky and the Sun takes up the
whole horizon sit here with me we know
in some places the clouds seem closer to
us than they do the sky and the Sun
takes up the whole horizon an interlude
to grow an ocean you stick a cloud on
the tip of your tongue and blow a prayer
a raging plea for bursting ground a
righteous
peace I have been dreaming of spirits
that sit in the Train on a bus in a tree
at the table something you walk through
that catches hands and spins
merry-go-rounds in our sorrow ancestral
souls whose backs cracked open and yoked
the hope holes yoke the holes full again
I do not mean to trivialize or beautify
the ugly I only mean to create a home a
heart that bleeds seeds of divine
qualification he who collects all my
tears in a bottle records them in a book
I didn't write that that was in Psalms
he who burns the book and writes new
ones
the spirit that I walk through I do not
mean to trivialize or beautify the ugly
I only mean to create a home a whimsical
sort of freedom unbound and Wow all we
want to do is break the chains off all
we want to do is break the chains off
all we want to do is be free all we
wanna do is be free J Cole an interlude
the leftover bacon grease from the pot I
cooked in last night stayed smeared on
the kitchen counter I hope the end I saw
crawling up the cabinet getting stuck
visitors are always welcome in my home I
peeled a potato and then a cucumber and
then an apple and a carrot and some corn
and then some squash and an onion and
then a Brussels sprout and then the
beans and also a tangerine eat with me I
only mean to create a home
[Music]
see I told Josh we're gonna let that
light in that was incredible and if it
feels like that deserves in a war like I
feel like we're like 20 years from now
we're bringing her back to do that you
know and so that's just a Neeta for you
and I think that's just like a glimpse
and also I forgot to mention that she's
directing a play called filling basins
the semester she's also the co-lead
coordinator for black church al so she's
just doing incredible things on this
campus right and I think that she is
somebody to know and to love and so now
I have the immense pleasure to introduce
professor me Addie
professor Addie received his BS at Duke
University and his PhD here at Yale and
neuroscience and he's been a Yelp
faculty member since 2010 so I'm gonna
read professors at ease about his
research because it's kind of a little
out of my room but it's super dope dr.
Eddy's research focuses on
neurobiological basis of substance abuse
anxiety and depression the goal of this
research are to provide new mechanistic
insight into these psychiatric illnesses
and to identify novel therapeutic
targets for treatment outside of the
laboratory dr. a irregularly contributes
to science outreach events from middle
and high school students and the general
public in addition he serves in several
mentorship and leadership roles related
to diversity and inclusion both here at
yo and nationally he has also had to
honor particular tissa paiting in
multiple college campuses
Veritas forums on the biological
psychological and spiritual assets
aspects of mental health so please join
me in welcoming professor Addie to the
stage
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for that generous introduction
it's great to see a full house tonight
we've been really encouraged by just the
conversations I've already started even
before we have this official
conversation tonight so I'm thankful for
all of you for coming out tonight
thankful for the enthusiasm and
motivation that people have had to
really have this conversation also want
to thank all those who have already
participated anita kinesia and and also
Jemima and pastor Orlando and for all
the worth of black church at Yale has
put into this event as well so let's
give them a round of applause
[Applause]
also want to give a special thanks to my
co-host so both Sharon koogler the
University chaplain who's here in the
front if we can give her in the gospel
[Applause]
and pastor Orlando peas the other
co-hosts with me then they both put in a
lot of force really getting this off the
ground so we're pleased to have everyone
everyone here tonight so as she
mentioned I'm a neuroscientist and the
researcher so one of the pieces that I
obviously think about quite a bit is the
component of mental health and I can say
that on our campus we have made a lot of
strides in terms of how we talk about
mental health focusing particularly
trying to decreases stigma that's
associated with those conversations but
clearly there's still a lot of room for
growth in these conversations and we
still have a lot to do and I would say
that's not something that's just so
unique to our campus but it's also true
nationwide again where there's been lots
of places where there's been improvement
in the conversation but still room for
growth and something that we're hoping
to continue to facilitate through the
conversation tonight
so really thankful that look crate has
actually taken time out of his busy
schedule to join us here I know this is
a topic that's very important to him as
well and I can tell you that his
schedule is very crazy
so Justin working with his team and all
the nuances and things that we've tried
to manage over time I'm really thankful
for his investment in our topic tonight
and thankful for all of you being
willing willing to be here and to really
jump into this conversation with us now
if they introduce of krei I could you
know stick to kind of the standard bio
and just talk about a lot of the
accomplishments that he's had and for
any of you who know about him we know
this wouldn't be that difficult to do
he's won multiple Grammy Awards multiple
DET Awards Dubb Awards it's had a New
York Times bestselling book it's had
multiple appearances on ve T good
morning Tamara
thank you which Jimmy Falon just to name
a few so obviously you know I can I can
give them some time to flex love it if
he wants to do when it comes up here but
for this part of the introduction I want
to step outside of those accomplishments
a little bit and talk a little bit about
some of this influence in other areas as
well so one of the things I've been
really impressed in kind of watching his
career development over the years is how
well he's really able to step into lots
of different venues and different spaces
and to be able to connect with people
with an authentic voice that then has a
real gifting and I think it's something
that's allowed him to really engage and
deepen rich conversations with people
and to have impact in people's lives as
well I was actually witness to that even
earlier today when we had a small group
gathering with some students here and
again just seeing his ability to really
engage in those challenging real and
tough conversations and to really have
impact so I'm grateful that he's taking
time out to come here and to be engaged
in that conversation with us here so the
way that this event actually came about
I had the opportunity to meet lecrae an
event back in April and basically just
from our conversation and talk about
some of these types of things it was
really clear to me that this was a topic
that really resonated with him so this
intersection of mental health faiths
culture and social justice and basically
tonight's event was really birthed out
of our mutual desire to see this
conversation on a much larger scale so
what we're really hoping for tonight is
that this would really just be the
beginning we don't want this to be a
one-time event we want this to be a
conversation that starts now or the
continues now and continues beyond
tonight as well but for tonight what
we're really trying to do is make sure
that we can really have a real open and
honest and respectful conversation that
really influences how each of us think
about this topic in our own lives and
also how we think about this topic and
the lives of those around us so with
that introduction that over the
background it's my pleasure to introduce
to the stage the great
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
was this my Creech okay good height
situation going on here well it's honor
to be here I'm really just a again blown
away at everything that I've experienced
since I've been here I came here a few
years back and I'm glad to be back on a
campus the Anita that was amazing first
of all I don't know where you are there
you go listen I don't know producers I
need new option for myself here oh well
I really believe that if this is gonna
be a sincere genuine conversation that
leaders lead a vulnerability and in
order to lead a conversation I have to
be vulnerable which I think will
generate and promote more vulnerability
I'm sure you probably some of you've
been in this room before or been in
rooms like it constantly it may not be
an environment that you necessarily see
is conducive for like sharing and
comfort but I just want you to imagine
this place as the most comfortable
environment that you can imagine one
where we're just here having a
conversation you're not being screened
you're not being judged you're not being
assessed there's no grades being handed
out at the able to situation this is
this is us being free to be ourselves
and you're welcome to join in that and
I'm also just going to allow you to if
you don't want to join the conversation
to have a window into my soul in the
process so start a little bit about
about me um I I'm just going right into
it I as we're talking about this
intersection of faith mental health
social justice I'm going to start with
the dark seasons that I've experienced
in life because I think that contributes
to all of those particular issues so for
me
let me set a timer because I can talk
alright we will not get anything else
accomplished in here today but for me I
actually recall the dark seasons of my
life starting as old as age seven right
so seven years old I was invited into
the room of a close family member and I
was taking advantage of sexually and so
here I am seven years old and I have to
now wear these scars on the playground
right I have to wear these scars amongst
my peers as their as a plan you know
Foursquare or whatnot I have to wear
these scars on Saturday morning when I'm
watching my cartoons I have to wear
these scars of this abuse in
environments with the exact person who
put these scars on me and act as if
nothing happened because it wasn't dealt
with it wasn't handed so I learned
something in that situation something
very unhealthy and when I learned was to
suppress trauma and pretend as if
nothing happened and just plow through
it was the first unhealthy lesson I
learned as far as trauma was concerned
was to just Hey box that up keep it
moving forward if you want to add to
that I grew up in an environment in a
home that was very unhealthy it was not
a healthy environment I was it was
filled with immaturity drugs it was
filled with just so many different
nuances that made it difficult for me to
have a healthy outlook on life four
years old my father was gone I never saw
him again
until 25 years later so you you you add
to that I was learning in that
environment who I was supposed to be
from the models in my community and so
what that led to is a young man who had
experienced you know everything from you
know physical abuse drugs as I said
before sexual abuse and now I was not
just the recipient of these things I was
starting to take on these
characteristics and flesh
I'm out on a day-to-day basis to where
the police were coming to my house
consistently I found myself consistently
depressed and in it is a messed up state
of being this is all before the age of
18 but I remember as a kid people saying
you remind me of your father you act
like your father you're just like your
father you're similar to your father and
I didn't take it as a compliment even if
it was just a mere observation I took it
as an insult
because this was a man that wasn't
consistent this was a man that had taken
on drug abuse it probably probably you
know has a lot of mental health issues
himself but I saw that as an example of
who I should not be and so what I did at
that point in time was consumed myself
with not being my father
I didn't consume myself with figuring
out who I was supposed to be I consumed
myself with not being this example of a
person so I took that initiative but the
problem in me trying so hard to not be
him as I didn't know who I was supposed
to be and on top of that all the trauma
that I had experienced throughout this
period of time I was just stuffing it
away all the pain all the abuse all of
those particular things I was stuffing
in a way because I had an agenda and I
had a mission and that was to not be my
father and so externally I was
succeeding right externally I'm
succeeding um I got scholarships I went
to college I made the Dean's List I
graduated I in turn I got a good
corporate job after corporate job I
started a business a successful business
at that but internally I was headed for
disaster
so externally I'm succeeding but
internally I'm failing tremendously but
I don't even realize it I learn to take
the worst circumstances of life and push
them deep down into this internal closet
and I'm bleeding internally but I'm
thinking I'm okay
right if you if you have a vital wound
and and you ignore it it doesn't get
better it eventually kills you so I'm
moving a million miles an hour now
there's a marriage of three kids it's
running multiple businesses the
successful music career
winning Grammys New York Times
bestselling author and then it all came
to a head in front of the world I was
this level-headed god-fearing man I'm
navigating everything just the way that
I should but behind the scenes I'm a
ticking time bomb ignoring all of the
trauma ignoring all of the weight of
these experiences and this depression
that is that is knocking at my front
door and it was during this time I
remember watching a video of a young man
probably about 15 years old in Chicago
and he's waving a gun around and
flaunting him and I remember something
being triggered right it moved me almost
to tears I learned about the facts of
the the murder rate in Chicago and I was
and I found myself sitting there
emotionally just devastated and I
couldn't understand why well truthfully
I had a friend who was taken by gun
violence at age 13 years old and that
trauma was triggered I didn't even
realize it I was the victim of you know
this witnessing death of a teenager and
then I'm seeing this other teenager just
flaunting and I didn't even connect
those dots
later that year I remember hearing about
the death of Trayvon Martin now I was
affected right I'm affected by this
murder I'm affected by what's happened
to Trayvon but I I didn't know how to
express it I didn't know what what
avenues or venues I had to express it
and so once again the same thing I had
learned previously to take trauma to
take traumatizing experiences and stuff
them away is what I practiced so I'm
disturbed to the core I'm fueled with
anger I remember as a kid seeing my
mother fueled with anger and frustration
after Rodney King was beaten down in her
hearing the verdict and all these
particular things happen but I don't
know how to navigate this particular
circumstance and so I'm sitting in a
similar position in the couple years
after Trayvon it was releasing McBride a
young teenager who got in a car accident
knocked on someone's door and was killed
because she was profiled and thought to
be you know committing a crime after
Renisha McBride there was Eric Gardner
and after Eric garner there was Michael
and so on and so on and Sandra and so on
and so on and so on and so on and then
and then and then there were riots and I
found myself sitting in the middle of
all this wondering where where do I fit
how do i how do i how do I react I was
trying to hide away the trauma of seeing
people who may as well been my cousin's
my sister's my nieces my aunts being
killed but it was overwhelming and I
found myself in the streets of Atlanta
involved in a protest so here I am
protesting there's students from all the
surrounding colleges in the area of
protesting with me and all of them are
looking to me for guidance for wisdom
for leadership and I'm just as lost as
they are have no idea how to navigate
everything that I'm dealing with and at
the same time I'm disrespected seemingly
conservative artist and a lot of my
supporters didn't like the idea of me
getting involved in what to them was a
political effect what are you doing
getting involved in this political
affair and so the dilemma that I had was
was was dual it was me trying to get
involved and do something about things
that I'm saying happening but then also
I don't even know who I am in the middle
of this so I'm trying to find myself I
don't know who I want to be and my
identity had already been forged by
finding approval in other people so I
was losing my approval rate was going
down in one particular group as I'm
trying to do what I felt to be right and
the traumas Wayne I felt what Moses if
you know anything about Moses Moses was
you know Hebrew by birth but he was
adopted by the Egyptian aristocracy and
it came upon him one day oh my goodness
I am Hebrew and the Hebrew people are
being oppressed by the Egyptians but yet
I'm a part of this Egyptian aristocracy
how does this make sense what do I do
and so I took a page out of Moses his
book you know what Moses did was he
killed somebody that's not what I did
I tweeted
same-same
I tweeted a lot right now so on I'm
tweeting but I'm saying things outside
of the boundaries of what people
expected of me I'm on national
television after this I'm writing
articles evidence I want to see you Ninh
and the result was this unadulterated
rejection so I'm despised now I'm hated
I've lost support regularly and and I
was about to learn a very beautiful
lesson that stays with me to this day
and that lesson was if you live for
people's except that you will die from
their rejection so I stood for something
but it felt like I lost everything I
worked so hard to not be my father to be
respected to be successful to be
accomplished to be accepted and now I'm
hated I mean in days days y'all lost
hundreds and thousands of social media
followers the drive a fifteen-year-old
crazy I was bombarded with messages of
people telling me how much respect they
lost for me I was bombarded with hateful
messages iced people sent me videos of
them burning my music like with fire
like at least they bought it though
see the bright side and everything right
um but I couldn't understand how they
didn't hear my pain how my sorrow in my
pain that I was already talked to
suppress and now here I was expressing
was being pushed away
it created a mental chaos for me and I
mean you know some of us to be expected
we don't always want to hear the voices
of people speak on you know social or
political things the Bronze Age stop
talking about this just play basketball
we don't want to hear that from you we
don't want to hear the nuance of who you
are but still I was at this crossroads
this downward spiral started to happen
in my life and at the lowest point I
started to get hate messages and death
threats on myself and my family racial
slurs consistently pouring in and I was
spiraling downward anger depression
sadness frustration a feeling of being
trapped and I didn't know what was real
I lost faith in people I lost faith in
God I lost faith in the faith so maybe
that's not your story that's not why
you're in this room right maybe that's
not how you came to a place of emotional
spiritual or mental chaos but you do
know what it feels like to have the
world sitting on your shoulders and you
feel so lonely you want to quit you do
know what it feels like to feel like
everyone's depending on you and this
pressure is overwhelming you do know
what it feels like for people to expect
your best but you're really at your
worst how do we navigate that how do we
navigate that chaos and how do we
continue dreaming and creating I wish I
could tell you I just woke up one day
and I just found some curve
you know what I don't care I wish I
could tell you that's the case I wish I
could tell you I just you know look deep
inside myself and I found something and
push through that's not what happened
what happened to me was I had to open
the closet I had to look in that closet
that I had stuffed away all of that
trauma all of that pain all of that
suffering and I had to stare it in the
face all of that failure
I had to stare it in the face I had to
look at it and allow it to make me a new
me I had to embrace the trauma and allow
it to mold me into something new see the
shift is being willing to die to
whatever it was that we were before the
pain to birth the person that we're
becoming like right the shift is
sometimes we're too attached to who
we've been so we're held back to who we
can become we don't understand that
there is no triumph without trial we
don't understand like working out in the
gym you've got to fail in order to get
stronger it's like a foreign concept so
I had to be willing to work and walk
through judgment and inconvenience in
order to grow I had to be willing to
become who I was created to be not who
they wanted me to be so it's scary right
it's you're standing at the edge of
something new you're afraid to jump and
you're you you don't know what that's
gonna what the cost the the opportunity
cost the cost analysis of that situation
is and so you're scared to jump I know
exactly was I could be scared to jump I
was in New Zealand and I'm on this this
uh this 700 foot tower and they say come
on man we gotta jump off this thing as a
base jump it'll be fun
and I was like I don't know if you check
my skin to only me but this is kind of
something black people don't do
but they convinced me man it'll be fun
we should do it they showed me a video
Beyonce jumping off of it but see
there's a million things be honest I can
do that I can't so that's not really a
good so I get up there and I'm telling
myself let's do it and I look down and I
see Tupac and Michael Jackson waving at
me
and I said I'm not gonna be able to jump
I can't do this on except fine came
about the way so it's 11 year old girl
can jump so then I had to jump oh but
I'm better because of it I wouldn't even
be able to tell you the story had I not
taken that job but we're so afraid to
jump because we're so focused on how far
the fall is we're so focused on what the
failure of that jump looks like and we
have to become something new we have to
take our traumas and allow them to make
us a part of who we want to be take the
terrible events and create a story of
triumph right athletes don't quit at the
toughest part of the game that's when
they want to play harder dream higher
push further become something new you
don't despise the caterpillar you don't
despise the cocoon that turns a
caterpillar into a butterfly right it
doesn't make sense and so sometimes
recognizing and realizing you know what
I'm broken and there's some issues in my
life that I need to address I need to
face I need to look at I need to talk
about is the only way to get to the
other side of them and had I not
addressed them had I not looked in the
closet had I not stared in the face of
these particular things I wouldn't have
seen what I believe God was trying to do
was make me into a better version of
myself was building me into something
else and so I own my store and that's
when we've got to have got to own our
story I had to own my store and say you
know this is who I am this is what made
me who I am this is a part of my journey
and because of that I am Who I am the
strength that I have is because of what
I've gone through these are our scars
right we show people our scars to prove
that healing is real if no one shows you
their scars you walk around believing
like there's no there's no way there's
no coming back from that but then here
are real life people saying no have
these same scars I survived and I'm
stronger and soul you but first you
gotta admit that's you're wounded you
know I could tell a million stories one
story that comes to mind is
rasaan harris who is incarcerated at San
Quentin ever sign was incarcerated
because he took a man's life and he's
doing 55 years to life when he went into
prison he was depressed he was angry he
was bitter he was frustrated because he
made a decision as a youngster that is
now affected the rest of his life but
after a few years he said you know what
I'm not going to allow this circumstance
to change my outlook on life I'm going
to use this time to become a better
version of myself
so he took financial literacy classes
it's a writing classes he became a
writer for the San Quentin newspaper
which is the only inmate operated and
run newspaper in existence his writings
and his stories now appeared in vice and
GQ and if the the board and the governor
and God are on his side which I believe
they are he's going to walk out paroled
with a career in journalism and stock
investments from all the years he was
investing while he was locked up and and
so had he sat in it and just said oh
this is my fate in life it would have
been a terrible situation but because he
said you know what I'm gonna let this
mold me into something new I'm gonna own
this I'm gonna admit this I'm in a bad
state and I'm gonna acknowledge it and
figure out how I can work through this
is the only way to come out on the other
side and so I'll say this that's where
my plane landed on my plane landed in
the acknowledging I'm broken
acknowledging I'm not perfect
acknowledging I don't get it all right
acknowledging I have a lot of wounds
that are now healed and have become
scars and I can stand here today and
show you my scars because those wounds
have healed but you've got to admit it
right and so that has restored my faith
in faith that has restored my faith in
God because God is the healer of all
things and my wounds are healed because
of him
and and I was fighting so hard to not be
my father right I'm spotting so hard to
not be my father
I didn't realize who I was supposed to
be so I'm at a
I'm at a track meet for my son my oldest
son is 10 years old he's running track
and track meets are extremely boring
they're long and hot his first event is
at 8:00 in the morning and the second
one they don't even tell you what it is
and it's at 3:00 so you're just sitting
there like when is it gonna come and I'm
there with my five year old and my five
year old is bored out of his mind so I'm
trying to keep his attention and I say
hey um what do you want to do with your
life I thought that was appropriate I
was trying I mean he's struggling right
like he's struggling like the weight of
the world on his five-year-old shoulders
he says daddy I don't know I just want
to be like you and listen I would not be
than me he wants to be like had I not
owned my past and present circumstances
failures situations and allowed it to
mold me into the me that I am today
there wouldn't be a me he aspires to be
had I not owned that so I mean I I say
to you all I'm grateful for the
opportunity to show my scars to admit my
brokenness and to allow that to continue
to make me into a better version of
myself thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
well thanks again still prefer for that
openness and that vulnerability I just
the way he's really been vocal about
speaking about these social justice
issues and also being vulnerable the
mental health aspect that's still being
bold about this face we definitely
appreciate view so this point we've been
in shift in the program to more of the
townhall piece of things but before we
do that I didn't want to acknowledge all
of our sponsors for tonight's event
which I forgot to do earlier definitely
important piece so one of the sponsors
is you or well that's been very integral
in sponsoring this event also the office
of the secretary and the vice president
for student life particularly comely
Gulf cruise who's here in the front so
thank you for it to you for your
sponsorship as well
also the chaplains office and Sharon
cooler in particular I'm also again the
black church video and my laboratory
specifically Erik Nunez and Durga after
you've been also integrally involved in
supporting this as well so with that I'd
like to invite lecrae back up to the
stage and pastoral and oh we're gonna go
into a little bit of a Q&A and this is
definitely an opportunity for all of you
to interact and be involved so we
definitely want this to be a
conversation especially with what
Lacroix was just brought forth to us to
really have a conversation amongst
essence really start to again begin some
of these important conversations which
I'm sure some of you have already had
but to continue those and continue
beyond tonight as well so I'm like
pastor Orlando McCray
this agent said oh yes signal
represented a black church this is going
to be interactive right but I just thank
all those who helped get us started in
this conversation I do recognize that
this is a ongoing conversation that
we're not launching it but we're just
helping it to continue to move a
question for you what did you hear and
the talk and the presentation what the
struggles Joy's stood out to you what
did you hear what do you want to know
more about if you can just take a minute
and think about that for some of you who
want to write it down please take an
index card and write it down what stood
out to you what stands out to you and
what do you want to hear more about if
you need an index card there are people
who can hand it to you or a pen people
who can hand it to you okay and this is
the rural black church experience turn
to your neighbor turn to a person next
to you if you don't know them introduce
yourself hi my name is
today shared with what is that you want
to know more about that is standing out
to you speak to each other
ever question that I want to pose to you
pose to look prey in in designing our
time together there were a number of you
who gave insight and feedback in terms
of what was important to you what
resonates with those around you what
resonates on this campus and we've taken
some of those questions and I'll ask
some of them now and I recognize there
are many more questions so one question
in the crate you can decide whether you
want to answer first and and I'll ask
four of you four of you here to respond
what are your biggest challenges to
maintaining a healthy mental state what
are effective practices for maintaining
a healthy mental state so what are your
biggest challenges to maintaining a
healthy mental state what are the
effective practices for you for
maintaining a healthy mental state go
first to pass oh yeah take the
microphone from a rapper come on in
again the biggest thing that I want to
acknowledge is that you you have to
recognize you need a healthy mental
state right and if you think you can
just plow through life without
investigating it's like driving a car
and never looking under the hood or
getting it checked out or just thinking
everything will be fine for life and I'm
sure to some people who do that now not
smart so so that was the biggest thing
for me was to acknowledge that even if I
feel like I'm able to accomplish the
things that I'm able to do on a regular
basis maybe I'm not healthy here and so
it's been going to see counselors or
therapy and to meet counselors is going
to get a check up on my car right it's
like once it's a physical it's taking
care of myself
so I'm that was step one I think for me
and then the continual practice almost
is now I have language or a playing
field to understand because I'm talking
to someone who you know is you know
trained in this particular area so now I
have language and practice to do some
self-care and and self-care for me I was
talking about this earlier it's
understanding that I need time to to not
be busy
I think busyness in many ways means your
life is out of control you don't have
control over it because you're so busy
so I need time I say I do DWA as a daily
diversion or weekly withdrawal and an
annual abandon and so a daily diversion
is just even if it's an hour just daily
where I can if I use my mind all the
time let me use my hands let me go play
with play-doh or color or do something
you know what I mean with my that's
where I'm I'm just diverted from all the
things I have going on a weekly
withdrawal is just taking a day weekly
and saying I'm gonna stop I'm gonna
pause I'm gonna do something that has
nothing to do with the things that are
stressing me out and then an annual
abandon is just taking some time every
year to get away from it all and and
that's that's me you know what I mean so
that's not necessarily the prescription
for everyone because everyone has
different issues going on but that's how
I'm taking care of myself
thank you there are four of you who
would yes
hi thank you so much for sharing how did
you mention God somehow did God help you
and I actually find it so interesting
how we're from different cultures but I
feel so much that you feel and I related
so much that this is my struggle right
now is walking and spirit and flesh at
the same time and it's such a struggle I
just talked to people today about that
and I was wondering if you had what you
do to do that
it seems the closer I get to God the
more the dark side comes up
I think it's that's one question anyway
Andy do you believe like in spiritual
deliverance and things like that like if
you have in any prayer cuz I know that
there's a lot of spiritual bondage when
you get into the abuse and and the way
that you've lived an abandonment you
mentioned what was the word you used
when you when you were the trauma from
when your dad left there was abandonment
and something else oops anyway just
wondering what you thought about that
because I'm very involved in church and
I do understand that there's a lot of
spiritual bondage and wondering what you
thought about that great question
so yes part of it for me was
understanding healing is a process right
so it's it's a continual process and I
tried to think of a time in my life
where God just you know he didn't come
through and I could
think of one right so that was part of
process was saying it's dependable
so let me trust him in this particular
circumstance and and then there's
there's so many different examples like
as I looked at job and looked at his
life and as I looked at lamentations and
just looked at Moses and it's like he's
not gonna
Joshua he's not gonna take you all the
way through the wilderness to the edge
of the Promised Land and then say bye
right so it's like there's a process of
coming through all of that in order to
get to this place and that process
involves trust and for me it was him
inviting me to trust him in the midst of
that madness
um I think personally it was very
helpful for me because I tend to wear
all of the burden on my own shoulders it
was helpful for me to know that God
wants to carry those burdens it was
helpful for me to know that he wants me
dependent and broken and not perfect and
put together and so I could relinquish a
lot of this that I had weighing on me in
his hands I mean I know that sounds
ethereal and just out there but part of
it was for me looking in in the text
looking at scriptures and seeing
promises and seeing these realities
flush themselves out and stop trying to
be or not be marthy father and focus on
my Heavenly Father you know that was a
big piece of it for me rejection
yeah I'm accepted so that was the
biggest piece tools I'm accepted right
like if if I'm accepted by the creator
of all creation why am i fighting for
everyone else's acceptance does it make
sense right so thank you someone else
Oh
thank you how to bring up a child from
the age of one week so that the child
will be confident kind in contrast to
being spoiled by getting a gold star for
doing nothing participation trophies
taking you're not a fan of those yeah I
mean again so let me say this yeah so
let me say this so so another thing I
talked about earlier was it's very
important for me to be healthy if I want
to create health in my family it's very
important for me to have a proper
perspective of Who I am and to have a
lot of the areas of my mental health and
trauma were identity issues I didn't
know who I was I didn't know who I was
created to be and so success was always
me comparing myself to other people
instead of comparing myself to what I
was supposed to do to what I had a
vision to accomplish it had really
nothing to do with everyone else around
me it should have had more to do with
the vision that I had and so for me it's
important to have to take proper care of
myself first before I take care of my
kids because if I'm not healthy I have
nothing to offer them and and then you
will tend to it pretty so like this if
you have what I would call like
functional saviors or scapegoats to deal
with your issues in life you're going to
re-implement that for your children so
if you think money will solve all of
your problems then you're gonna teach
your children the same thing and they're
gonna think that there's some kind of
crush they can lean on um I stopped
rewarding my children with desserts and
things along those lines when they are
well and the reason why is because I
didn't want them to feel like eating
unhealthy was how they should reward
themselves in life right because then
that you know I and I you know so it's
like oh you're sad come on let's go get
a cheeseburger let me cheer you up with
an ice cream cone because then what does
that teach them down the road like well
I'm sad I'm gonna eat this whole
chocolate cake because I swear right so
I have to know that about myself first
and so a lot of it has been me having to
learn these particular thing thank you
the microphone is are in charge thank
you so much for your talk and your
vulnerability I'm wondering how you use
your trauma and or what your experience
with mental health in your art in and
I'm wondering if if you do use it if
you've because I'm wondering about the
idea of expressing yourself as a
holistic person just if you could talk
about that yeah I think this that's good
I think
expression specifically like in art is a
part of owning your narrative right and
when you can own your narrative it's no
longer a tool of oppression against you
it's a it's a tool of empowerment right
so I can own my narrative and I own is
that the most amazing things
Eminem ever did way back when was when
he wrote you know lose yourself and he
did the whole 8 mile movie he cut his
own legs off he acknowledged his own
weaknesses before anyone else could and
and for me art is been a place to
acknowledge openly my weaknesses
acknowledge my struggles now
sometimes I'm acknowledging them for
myself not for the world to hear but
specifically when there's weaknesses or
issues that I have
processed and I have gone through and
I've gotten help with and I have been
counseled through I don't mind talking
about those publicly because I'm on the
other side of it and and they're not
they're not you know stories for me to
be ashamed of there's stories that I
triumph through and have made me a
better version of myself and so art is a
has been very therapeutic for me in that
regard because I can talk about it and I
can express it I don't think every piece
of art needs to be heard or seen but
they need but need to be created for
sure I have a question how would you
necessarily respond to someone say like
in the church who says like mental
illness doesn't exist just pray about it
God's gonna handle it and just leave it
at that and then my second question is
how do you view like suicide I'm in a
church I can't remember the pastor's
name but more recently in the media
there was a pastor who died by suicide
and it's been like more so on the
forefront with the church and people
saying like by him doing that he was
selfish and condemning him and like God
doesn't like that like how would you
respond to like the criticisms like that
yeah I'm a very sensitive specifically
when I think we saved the church and I
think there's this homogeneous t'k kind
of perspective of what that means and so
it's easy to like say this is what the
church thinks the church is not a
homogeny there's there's there's there's
individuals within that have unique
perspectives on things and some of them
you vehemently disagree with and some
you love and you do agree with and so um
so as it pertains to like what the
church says about mental health I don't
I don't know I know the the the church
that I interact with sees it as of as
necessary as sees it as very beneficial
to seek self-care and and counsel and
therapy
and whatever is necessary and so I can
speak on behalf of those a group of
people those who would say that I would
say tell them to stop going to bed every
night and you know because if you just
need to pray about it then don'ts don't
sleep just pray about it you don't need
to sleep why are you sleeping pray about
it God will deliver you you can make it
you know that means it's just you know
so we're we're we're here as cricket
sticks drawing straight lines right and
so we're not here to be perfect
Android's right we're here as examples
of what a great God can do with broken
people and I think that's the difference
there and so um and and that I think
that carries over into you know criminal
activity that carries over into you know
depression that carries over into all
those particular issues as suicide
included that that's evidence of broken
hurting people right it's not that
there's no reason to cast judgment or
throw stones in that particular
circumstance that's just the evidence of
broken people that God still uses in
different ways that are beyond our
comprehension its arms so my perspective
so additional questions that some of you
submitted ahead of time just to know if
there are more questions you know what
are some of the barriers that prevent
people from seeking out mental health
services what is the current state of
mental health conversations in our
society on college campuses at Yale how
do you kind of have an effective
work-life balance I want to
give us another opportunity to interact
with your neighbor the person next to
you first to take a minute and think in
the realm of social justice what are
some of the positive changes that you've
tried to make in your life or the life
of those around you and the midst of
ongoing social justice challenges so
what are some of the positive changes
that you've tried to make in your life
or the lives of those around you and the
midst of ongoing social justice
challenges
so getting about 10 minutes just to
think about it or 10 seconds to think
about it today the law it's alright yo
people and we can you know share with
the person next to you have a
conversation with the person next to you
and they will come back to additional
questions and comments this is good this
is good
excellent this is good hopefully you
weren't talking about what's in a dining
hall but you actually in conversation
about which what's of importance to you
if you would go ahead and share yeah so
social justice and there's there's many
facets of it right and I've been
involved in a number of different facets
of of what we would say social justice
is um it's made me a better person in a
multitude of different ways so on 11.1
it's made me stop seeing myself as a
commodity being able to be bought
because there's a there's a sacrifice
that I had to make financially
commercially whatever you would call it
to say things that weren't palatable for
parts of society and it's easy to just
kind of try to toe the line and and walk
the fence in order to secure its show I
mean it exposed parts of my heart that
were just financially motivated and I'm
not saying we shouldn't be responsible
but I'm saying we should care and um and
and so I would go from doing a show for
3,000 people and then as I started to
raise my voice on issues of police
brutality um those shows shrink
dramatically um it's so did my account
but it freed me it freed me to be myself
another way that it made me better was
it made me very because of the issue
that I saw happening in my community in
the black community it made me more
attune to other communities
um and so then I had to ask myself how
misogynistic how patriarchal am I and
how can I care about these issues of
black people but not care about the
issues of women right and so I had to
start digging more and growing in
multitude of different other areas other
ethnicities and begin to care
as a global issue as well thank you are
there for bus who can contribute hi I'm
speaking about community I was just I
just wanted to know what is the role
that a community can play in in the
healing process and in addressing mental
health issues specifically to you in
your experience do you have a community
with which to join you want to talk to
you to consult you know and to go
through that you're going through and my
second question is how do how do we as
Yale students from where the communities
where we come from like for example I
come from South Africa so how do I go
back there and like create our work in
the community where I come from and
particularly imagine arise community so
like where people feel that they are
certainly more pressing issues than
mental health for example poverty
unemployment drugs you know those are
seen at least people feel that they're
more urgent or more important than
actually mental health so how do you
create dialogue in such a community how
do you create conversations and how you
bring about that intersection so having
the faith community to that conversation
area bring the culture to that community
and also social justice as well so there
are two questions basically I have and
also how do we create these
conversations in the communities we come
from I shall be brief because I noticed
a lot of other comments as well what
we're in South Africa are you from my
second home soon right on yeah I just
got back from South Africa so shout out
to you congratulations you made it so on
question 2 you talked about how do you
lead in those particular I think leaders
lead and vulnerability right so you've
got to be the vulnerable one and show
the the the example of how you know
you're still here irregardless of the
scrutiny or whatever you may have faced
for being honest about issues of mental
health issues of societal injustice
social injustice
um you addressed it you live through it
you still got all your limbs and you're
sitting at Yale University right so I
think you are a living breathing example
for a lot of people specifically in
those marginalized communities that it
can be done you give them the freedom
you give them the power to do that to
the first question communities
everything if you don't have a community
to express these particular things with
then you begin to build it and sometimes
I know for me building community I had
to let my guard down with people that I
might have otherwise disagreed with in
my more arrogant self-contained
self-sufficient self-sustaining version
of myself the more dependent version of
the person that said you know what I
don't know everything I don't have it
all figured out may relationships across
the divide and so now I'm having
conversations with a young lady who I
I would not have agreed with on certain
things but I do agree with her on mental
health or the issues of womanhood and
now I'm like whoa
what else can I learn from her you know
I wouldn't have otherwise not had a
conversation with her because I
disagreed so vehemently on these
particular things and now we're
dialoguing more and we're becoming good
friends and I think that's happened very
consistently for me and I think that's a
part of you know what happens as well
but so yes so um I have bipolar disorder
and I've had a really great fortune to
have medication and therapy I'm also a
songwriter and I've been able to use
music to process a lot of that and my
faith has also been a very instrumental
part of my recovery I'm also in a band
with a couple other people who also have
bipolar disorder so a lot of our songs
are about mental health about recovery
about healing from abuse and trauma
recovery from addiction and even with
with the help I've had moments and
experiences of just really being baffled
I had to resign from my job teaching and
to take care of my mental health and
through that I also had a profound sense
that God was working through my mental
illness to bring me in closer
relationship with him to bring me into
my own purpose and my as you were saying
sort of a truer version for myself and
so my question sometimes when I'm
experiencing something is is this God or
is this bipolar
[Applause]
exactly yeah and that's been Lancers
that's often God working through my
mental illness and my question is how
can we help people navigate those spaces
I've talked to a lot of people who I
don't really have a framework or
language to talk about God and mental
illness is aim steps or in the same
conversation people who you know at
church don't hear much about they might
not hear a lot about mental illness and
then in mental health settings not
hearing much about God so I'm wondering
if there are ways we can help people
integrate the two I think this
conversation here is a great example of
one way and I'm wondering what other
ways might look like that's great great
more power to you love you thank you for
your vulnerability - I'm a so long way
to answer this question um I was in
Paris and I was so excited about being
in Paris it was like honest dreams
romantic city I can't wait to see
everything and talk to these people is
gonna be great the food's gonna be
amazing and then I got to Paris and I
couldn't understand anything and no one
would accommodate my American privilege
and speak English to me and and I
struggled and I hated it and I couldn't
I couldn't read the menus and I couldn't
understand where I was going and no and
no one would explain to me anything and
and I was just so disappointed it
frustrated I just opted to eat at
McDonald's because I was tired right but
I have a friend of mine who's been there
for a year now and he said I felt the
same way you did but then I wrestled
through all of the complexity of it and
saw the beauty in the complexity and now
I love
of Paris and I say that to say this that
many times especially in the in the in
the in the faith community we it just in
general we struggle with the nuance we
struggle with complexity we love it easy
and in in there's beauty and complexity
and wrestling with nuance and many times
we're creating new categories for people
that they just are what mental health
faith ah too much I can't do it in but
this is evidence that that's a category
that needs to be walked through and it's
often difficult and frustrating but when
you get to the other side it's worth it
and so and I've seen that time and time
again in my life that I'm constantly
creating new categories and breaking
barriers that people just didn't think
could exist um but but then people get
to see the beauty of it once they get on
the other side so this is that as you're
talking about and I think it's
continuing this even though it's
difficult and ugly continue pushing
through to create new categories and
wrestle with nuance and seeing the
beauty and the complexity yeah so you
previously talked about how as you get
more you get more involved in social
justice you experience this rejection
and I know previously you've talked
about how you had to break up with white
evangelicalism and I know that for me
personally that breakup has been a
freeing and so liberating in many ways
and has I think rejuvenated my faith and
my call to ministry in many ways so I'm
interested to know what that breakup did
for you and how that has kind of helped
you to regain that faith in God and your
mental well-being yeah I think in the
podcast you know it was suggested Oh
sounds like you've broken up with white
evangelicalism and for me um even though
I was still processing in a moment but
what that meant and what it means for me
more than anything is
not believing that there's one sect of
my faith one group of people within that
that has all the answers right and I
think I just stayed on one track and
kept reading only the people's books on
this Trek and and I didn't even read
these books because they said all the
negative things about these authors and
so I only knew what was wrong about
these authors I never understood what
was right and I never realized or
assumed or came to conclusion that wait
this Trek could be wrong right like
there's things wrong here that are not
being acknowledged I mean so for me that
was it was more about saying I'm not
excluding myself from these perspectives
you know globally historically that it
just aren't talked about right um
usually when we talk about church
history for whatever reason it jumps
straight from you know Israel to Europe
and I was bad for me I'm like wait a
minute what about the Ethiopian that
left Rose the church hey you know Asia
the Middle East the sea reacts the
Coptics
none of those stuffs ever mentioned and
and that's what helped me realize is a
very Eurocentric colonized view on
christianity that i was embracing and i
said i'm not gonna do that i'm going to
see it globally and and that means
there's gonna be perspectives that are
gonna fight against each other but
that's okay because I think God likes us
to not have all the answers and when any
camp says they have all the answers
that's the camp you might want to stay
away from just saying thank you so much
lecrae and I just wanted to actually
respond to the previous comment about
other settings of the intersection of
mental health
and faith and so even I can speak for
myself as well as a mental health
provider and there are several in the
room as of all who are people of faith
and from personal experience it's
something that incorporates in the
clinic practice with my patients
I've even prayed with my patients as
well and so there are people who will be
open about that not with every patient
but there are times where I may feel led
to discuss that and I feel that you know
people can be receptive because they're
looking for like the biopsychosocial
spiritual that aspect and many people
also use their faith as a coping
mechanism coping strategy and so I think
that that's also important and I also
try to incorporate that as well so
that's another venue and Ament and as I
mentioned there are several people in
this room who are mental health
providers of faith you know who practice
a you know who are a Christian so thank
you thank you and thank you keep going
buy some copies of my man's bipolar band
and gets in them out
junkyard forego stream that stream that
I really appreciate the conversation and
so this is another opportunity to
interact with your neighbor and instead
of me posing a question this time that
that comment that you have that you want
to say please turn to your neighbor and
share that comment share that insight
just what's coming up for you now what
you're thinking about what you're
holding on to that is either a struggle
or maybe a big win for you in this
moment please turn to a person next to
you and share please leave no one out
and sharing
okay we'll come back together and I want
to ask the crave this this final
question that I have and also open it up
to four of you to share looking at
culture
how do culture cultural background and
cultural perspectives influence your
view of yourself and how you interact in
society so how do culture and cultural
background and cultural perspectives
influence your view of yourself and how
you interact with society Wow
when I when I speak on this I'm speaking
as a journeyer you know someone who's on
the journey not someone who's reached
the pinnacle and has the solutions right
so as I speak about it I'm not speaking
I'm speaking as an expert from
experience not an expert from like oh
I've researched this and I have the
answers right so but in my experience
similar to what what my friend here was
talking about in terms of God using his
his being bipolar I think my cultural
experiences have been those detrimental
and painful have been used to shape a
lot of who I am now and it's been me not
being ashamed of them but to say no this
is a part of my narrative and narrative
is no one we all learn from narrative
right we love narrative we learned from
story especially stories of trial and
triumph and so no one wants to go to a
Lord of the Rings film and just see
there's a kid who lost his way
the ring and thought that ring was a
part of himself but it wasn't and then
he found himself for now the end like we
want to see the whole thing play out and
and and I think we forget that we're in
a narrative like where our narratives
being written we're part of a grand
narrative and so I feel like culture in
many ways shapes you know our views on
the world and that's why we oftentimes
need to come together with other
cultures to like have a complete
perspective and sometimes it's negative
and sometimes it has its benefits I
don't think it's all like I can't look
at how I came up or what I came through
and and think it is the best or the way
and I think that's where the danger lies
so so another analogy I use um I use
analogies often and drive my wife crazy
but it's how I communicate is if I'm at
a baseball game I hate baseball by the
way but if I was to be at a baseball
game if I'm sitting outfield watching
the game I would think I have a great
perspective of the game but then someone
sitting behind the the batter would say
no I have a great perspective of the
whole game and meanwhile the pitcher
saying no I'm in the game I have a great
perspective of the game and I think the
reality is every one of those particular
people have a vantage point but it's the
collective that is you know helpful for
them to see where they lack and to see
you know what other people don't see and
I think that's what for me my cultures
helped me to see things that other
people don't see so when people say all
the Black Panthers is a terrorist group
I'll say uh they fed my mother as a
child when she was starving so various
perspectives so
I have a question especially my question
really just has to do with you mentioned
there like you like join these movements
and suddenly like all these radians were
going down and all these trends and then
you put forward like I'll find you the
trap say Amen and you would slip by the
way oh I'm such a Hughes ik but my
question is how then did you bring
yourself around to learn to trust people
again and to learn to love and because
you mentioned how important it like the
approval of people was for you so going
through that period of rejection how how
do you love people authentically even
after what they've done to you oh yeah
that's good that's really good um that
took time I'm not gonna lie to you doubt
took time it's it was a season of just
like you know yeah just certain authors
my stomach like thought that book in a
trash you know I mean just um but part
of it is as you mentioned like I'll find
you I'm just a bigger song I've ever put
out in my career in the darkest time of
my life and I think that's part of the
lesson that God said we're good you saw
my acceptance not other people's and
look what I did in that process right oh
you are fighting for acceptance you hit
a ceiling but when you stopped fighting
for acceptance and just for
authentically yourself look at what
happened and people are drawn to
authenticity anyway so you liberated a
lot more people than you would have ever
imagined so that was part one and then
in trusting and loving people again it's
just really hard to be hopeful and
hateful at the same time right it's
really hard to be hopeful and hateful
and so as my hope increased my love
increase for other people because as I
have a hope in in and of myself it's
just really hard for me to to just look
at someone else and say you just make me
sick right you know so so the trust was
a process it would didn't happen
overnight
but as I took time for self-care to grow
I found more security I understood
myself more I filled in some gaps right
in my own understanding about faith
about you know I read a lot of books
from all over the world from different
authors that I wouldn't have otherwise
read and gaps got filled in and then I
was hopeful and I was like oh this is
great it's like well I'm not mad at
y'all the more I feel bad for y'all
because I know things that y'all don't
it's pretty bad y'all don't know this
you know what I mean and so it was a
process if you didn't hear her she was
asking for stratus strategies to a fight
what feels like a continual state of
brokenness and I met my youngest son was
a very very pitiful child I mean just
being honest he he couldn't dress
himself he used the bathroom on herself
constantly couldn't feed himself just
really pitiful his sadness and but I
wasn't frustrated at him because he was
my son and and because even though
performance-wise
he was a mess positionally he was my son
and he was gonna be great and i'll
change his diapers for him and I'll feed
him in this process and I think we in a
state of perpetual brokenness sometimes
our performance seems poor and that's
that's okay sometimes because it reminds
us of our positioning and I think the
strategy for me in a place where I feel
like I just can't get past how ugly
everything feels and looks around me um
it made me that much more dependent and
then I began to be disciplined in
dependency because I didn't have a
choice
alright if you've ever been
sick or broken a limb you you learn how
to become dependent on other people or
you learn how to you know function in a
new kind of way and that's what happens
to me in that state is just constant
dependency dependency on God dependency
on friends kind of throwing myself on
the train tracks of faith and what that
means is even if it seems like black ink
on white pages I'm just gonna read it
I'm gonna read it I'm gonna keep reading
it I'm gonna keep reading it until it
gets in me you know and I'm gonna put
myself around people that I know mean me
well and not harm even if I don't feel
like being around them and I'm gonna
fight to become a dependent person until
it's like oh wow I am out of this
position I'm healed thank you hi thanks
for being here my question is sort of on
the flip side of kind of dealing with
haters and people who don't necessarily
agree with you kind of in your process
of rise to success how have you managed
to stay humble and you're also talking
about a big part of mental health being
the communities that you kind of go back
to for support has has that sort of rise
to fame made you alienated at all felt
alienated like you can't like sort of
people can't maybe relate to you in the
way that they used to first of all I
don't know who told you I was humble
I'm not I'm constantly practicing the
art of humility it's a lifetime struggle
so I feel free to join me yeah so
humility is just daily like reminding
yourself I read a book on it every year
you know I find a different one if I
need to but um you know there's just a
lot of different perspectives part of it
is like just reminding myself of how big
God is and then you allow yeah I'm small
that's good good reminder but yeah and
and keeping close friends around me so
to answer your question um yes I do keep
close day one original friends who know
me as me not me who rose to whatever
around because they keep me humble it's
very hard for them to see the difference
they're like why do they want your
autograph that's stupid you know so I
keep those people around but but then
yes it is hard because it takes them a
while to breathe that air right it takes
them a while and they have to adjust
Oprah said it once she said me and my
friends have struggled to breathe in my
hair and um and I was like what is she
talking about you know what I mean I
just yeah I don't get it but then I did
understand it after a season and it's
kind of like you know I'm leaving Jimmy
Fallon and my friends are like go let's
stand outside and look around and take
pictures and I'm like I can't do that
right like there's a you know just
different little things little nuances
that they have to learn like oh that's
right your life sucks
but but then over time they you know
they I tell them and they understand
they grasp it and and they serve me in
that capacity and they start trying to
protect me and those are the people all
on one around people who don't try to
take advantage of the unique
opportunities I have but want to protect
me from other random stuff so yeah thank
you thank you so much I I'm just in
wonder cuz there's so many elements that
I want to talk about for like three
hours and there's like just keep
tracking on top of them but one of the
things that a word that keeps coming
through this presentation through this
town hall is wholeness
I keep thinking returning the brokenness
and wholeness and wholeness in
brokenness but you know in this cultural
section I feel as though a lot of times
I've also segmented parts of myself and
ignored parts of myself and I feel as
though I'm in an environment here at
Yale which encourages me to walk on my
hands and I get strong walking on my
hands thinking not feeling being able to
analyze and not empathize and I want to
ask how do you stop yourself when you
find yourself continuing to walk on your
hands it's continuing to go back to that
self that's only a part of you and not
the whole you you already accomplished
the first step is you acknowledged you
plowing through you acknowledge that
you're walking on your hands right um I
think it should be an encouragement to
you that when you said that how many
people in this room groaned
you're not alone right there's a room
for the people who are like I agree and
I think you foster that community and
you you become look at me man I'm
wearing pants in these pants these don't
make sense
these don't make sense but I don't care
cuz I like them so I'm gonna wear them
and my words my value is not diminished
some people are saying some people are
saying yeah he's like artists with
artists you know but I'm like I wanna
wear them so I wear them and and I think
it's that that's that's what a
prestigious institution builds builds
that kind of character that that kind of
authenticity that says you know I'm Who
I am and who I am you know it is
accepted and you have a community here
that accepts you and you're not fighting
for their acceptance you're not fighting
for anybody's acceptance you're being
who you authentically should be that
sort of success is right and so I think
it's resting in those moans that you
heard it's resting in all the people
that you know cuz truthfully that's how
everybody's feeling bro that's the odd
feeling that they're just afraid to show
it they're afraid to say I want to be
accepted by everybody so I'm not gonna
be my real self
they're afraid to say that but it's the
truth everyone's in the performance trap
and you know we were talking early and I
said the thing about you all here is
you're so exceptionally gifted and
you're in an arena where all the
emphasis is put on how exceptionally
gifted you are academically but that
doesn't mean you're whole
emotionally mentally spiritually right
does it why do they put a gym on campus
cuz they know so just it's okay
acknowledge it living it walking it
breathe it in and own it man
own that owning I'm tired of walking on
my hands I'm not gonna do it and there's
other people around you that's how
movements get started so like a little
video it's funny is like a guy on a
hillside you know and he's like dancing
crazy in front of a bunch of people just
chilling and looking at my board but
then the second guy comes up and starts
dancing with them and and then that
second guy is the person that starts the
movement right it's all it takes is one
of the person to stand beside you and
after the second guys in the third then
the fourth and the fifth and everyone
else I don't want to be left out I'm
gonna be left out they wanted to get up
and they were so afraid of what everyone
else would say the groupthink happened
but but the beauty of the was somebody
had to be the first person to say I felt
like dancing I'm dancing so more power
to you you heard the moms we wish you
man yeah name is Jay Morris and I'm
gonna thank you I had to call my
children to mass then hula Cray was I
wasn't sure but then they told me to
come anyway but but one of the things
one of the things they think that you
mentioned and I think this is part of
the experience that we have is that we
talked about the church and going to the
church and I think many of us have gone
to the church and have felt neglected
and abandoned and so one of the things
you've done here you talk about
transparency vulnerability and when you
look at the the New Testament you came
to Christ as you were I think so often
we're afraid to do that
you talked about authenticity and
intentionality so I appreciate the fact
that I'm asking what can I get from this
but it's a reminder of me that that that
learning process is ongoing and and this
looks like a church and we're having
church because there's a level of
openness and transparency that we can't
always have in a church and so I think
is we take this away and I do a lot of
work with leaders we don't have this
conversation because there's a sense of
I can't let other folks know where I am
and you also talk about our community in
our culture's a lot of our culture and
communities are surrounded by violence
but we live in that space and so it
becomes a commonplace thing but what
you've created here is the sense of and
so for me this is church this is what
church is supposed to be about and so I
think as we in here leave to trust to
love to reach out to one another because
people are hurting and you've said that
and if we can create that sense of
church I think where we are it's
important but but I'm curious in terms
of when when did you come into that
space where were you realize your faith
and what that meant to you what was
there a place or time when you just
stepped in that space in selkie no I'm
gonna be me this is who God created me
to be and if anyone else's problem that
that's their problem when did you come
into that space was like you know what
this is who I am yeah I think over the
last two years is you know I've always
acknowledged my faith you know since I
you know became a believer but I think
over the last two years
it wasn't groupthink it wasn't going
along with everyone's what people will
pat me on the back for and because I
grew up fatherless and I'm not saying
that's the reason for everyone's
situation but for me that was the
ingredient for my desire for acceptance
and approval um was because I didn't get
that affirmation like no one ever said
you know so I want to tell you did a
good job I never heard that
so I long to hear it somewhere and um
and and it wasn't until I said Oh God
already said that you know what I mean
god I said I love you and I'm proud of
you and keep going keep trusting me and
you don't have it all together but
that's okay I do
oh that's free that's liberating well
let me just be who I'm supposed to be
and I think unfortunately for me I had
to go through hell to get there right I
had to be pushed to the edge of you know
insanity um so I was left with no choice
I don't want that for anybody I don't
want anybody to get to the ledge and be
like you know hopefully that people will
I got said be broken before you are
broken you know what I mean that's what
my hope will be for everybody
hello so I guess my question is is I was
just speaking with my stepson about my
challenges of balancing my work life and
my personal life and so my main
challenge is that I feel like everybody
has a need for me and I have to be after
we're a million hats and they have to be
a hundred different places and how do I
be able to take care of my own self and
take time out for myself when I have so
many people that have all these demands
on myself every scenario is different so
I can't speak to your specific
circumstances right I can speak in
generalities I could speak about my
experience and for me what I've had to
do is like I said before I think you
know sometimes busyness means we're out
of control right so it's taking back
some of the control and and a large part
of that for me has been you know
creating prioritizing space for rest
prioritizing space for self-care it's
not me being selfish it's me actually
trying to care about everyone else and
if I'm gonna lose my mind I'm no good
for y'all so I prioritize it and we
prioritize lots of things right if
you're involved in any kind of
extracurricular you somehow found a way
to prioritize that and to put that in
your life if you if you're caught up on
any Netflix series you've prioritized
that to make that a part of your life
so it's prioritizing those breaks in my
life and it's it's putting them on a
calendar saying you can't touch it
nothing nothing can touch this well what
are you doing I'm walking through a
graveyard in the middle of the day cuz
nobody will talk to me if it's weird I
don't care but nothing can touch that if
I might as well be at you know the
hospital visiting my sick mother you
can't touch that time it's always been
for me creating those spaces where I'm
like if I don't get this I'm gonna lose
my mind so I've got to create this space
that just has to happen you know and so
even with you know um I give my wife
Tuesdays off so Tuesdays I'm like go
live life I got them everything don't
even come home from sunup to sundown now
you don't you don't you don't have any
responsibilities
like you know I'm saying like but no
literally she'll come home in the middle
of day and the house is on fire and I
got kids everywhere and stuff and then
they'll be like mommy she says I don't
exist bye
and she was like walk through the house
but it's like but we created that space
you know it's like nothing nothing can
stop it and so no matter what
opportunity or whatever it's like this
is blocked right you know what I mean
it's so home that's what I would say is
just create like prioritize whatever it
needs to be prioritized for you to feed
your soul feed your mind your emotion
your health whatever it is I'm gonna
help us to transition and so ongoing
work and ongoing conversation and I will
ask the Cray to give us foster send us
off and I will invite on University
chaplain Sharon cooler up to close the
Cray mentioned that it's the second
person who stands beside the first
person that starts the movement I
recognized tonight that we are the
second person and some of you in this
room are the first person who you've
been having these conversations you've
been doing this work you may have
created resources you may have created
space for this type and one of the
things I've learned about you know for
my time here is that I don't know all
that I should know about what
opportunities exist and who else may be
interested in something that I'm
interested in there are some comments
tonight that I think some of you may
have heard and said I'm actually doing
well in that area
and I'm willing to share how I'm having
victory in that area and there's some of
you tonight who might have heard
something I said you know what this has
been a pain in my existence for a while
but I'm willing to step out and say this
is the pain of my existence and I wanna
conquer this thing is anybody open to
that you have index cards they're more
index cards aver
you'll like them I would like to receive
and we would like to receive your
contact information and what is that
work that you're doing what are those
conversations that you're having or that
you want to start having around any of
these topics or other topics and my
promise to you it's hard making a
promise my promise to you is to collect
that and send it back to every
registrant who provided an email address
to say this is where we can continue the
conversation on campus and this is the
work that we can do and I know that
there are professionals in the audience
who think about these topics often and I
would like a way to just to harvest your
generosity and to share it in ways that
allow you to keep your mental health in
ways that support you so if there's an
index card that you would like please
ask if there's a pen that you would like
please ask and we'll collect it before
it's over if you did not provide your
email address but you would like to
receive that information please also
write that on an index card and we will
collect it so that's the crate to send
us off or something and then sharing to
come forward all I would say before you
know exit is like I'm gonna leave you're
gonna continue to be here wrestling and
so I think it's very crucial that you
make these connections and with with the
the leadership the wisdom in this room
and one another and really foster this
community because it's very easy for
somebody like me to pop in drop a bomb
everyone's like yeah it's good and then
I leave and that's it but it's hopefully
I'm here just as a inspiration for you
to continue doing what you're already
doing and to continue to do more than
that so that's my hope in my prayer that
when I come back next time
you know it'll it'll be even greater
thank you and those of you who are
willing to share your story and to be in
conversation with someone just to be
that vulnerable please say so I just
want to thank everyone who came out I
want to especially thank Orlando and me
who became new good old friends in these
last few months thank you for all the
work that you did for all the volunteers
thank you to Kim for coming and Lecrae
thank you for the gift of your words and
your presence and your spirit and as you
were speaking I was thinking he's taken
words and he's he's reinvented them to
the good and in particular I was
thinking about failure as birth as a
beginning that when you talked about
building on that and lifting your
brokenness it's something we all need to
hear at this place that demands
perfection which I think can finish us
but failure can begin us and so you gave
that to us tonight I want to invite you
all to take a deep breath we're going
back out there
but we're not going back out there alone
we shared some important things tonight
I thank you for your bravery that's
another word that we need to claim to a
different end a bravery that's radical
and how far and wide we embrace others
and how far and wide we embrace
ourselves and our brokenness so god
bless each and every one of you go in
peace and breathe good night
[Applause]
[Music]